So I want you to imagine sitting in the passenger seat of a car.
Okay, sure.
A self-driving car, right? And you are just zooming down the Las Vegas strip.
Oh, nice. Neon lights. Totally smooth ride.
Exactly. Everything is flowing perfectly. And then, out of nowhere, the car just violently slams on the brakes.
Oh, man. Yeah, your heart just completely drops into your stomach.
Right. You look out the windshield and there's, you know, there's no pedestrian, there's no red light, no debris in the road. It's
just an empty street.
Yeah. And up until recently, if you asked the engineers why the car did that, you would basically just get this frustrated shrug.
Which is, I mean, it's the ultimate paradox of modern AI, isn't it?
Totally. We
build these incredibly sophisticated systems to navigate the real world. But when they do something weird or unexpected, they act like locked black boxes.
Right. They take in all the sensor data.
Gigabytes of it. Yeah. And they do math we can't easily follow and then spit out a breaking command. When you ask it why, it's just total silence.
But I mean, if you are sitting in that car, trusting it with your life, silence is not an acceptable answer.
No, definitely not.
So today we're doing a deep dive into a really groundbreaking September 2026 nature paper. It's by E.O. and Kenny and a team from MIT CSAIL, along with the autonomous vehicle company Motional.
It is such a cool paper.
It really is. We're going to unpack how they finally took that black box and basically made it talk.
Yeah. They got a two ton vehicle to explain its reasoning on public roads.
Real public roads in real time using a vocabulary that a human driver can actually understand.
Which is a massive leap, taking explainable AI off a controlled computer screen and putting it on actual asphalt at 40 miles per hour.
With a human safety driver inside. It's wild. But, you know, to appreciate why this is such a huge deal, we kind of have to look at the fierce debate tearing the AI community apart right now.
Oh, the architectural battle over black boxes. Yes.
Right. It really centers on Cynthia Rudin's famous stance from back in, I think, 2019. Yeah.
Her 2019 Nature Machine Intelligence paper. She came out swinging.
She really did. What was her main argument there again?
She basically said we have to stop trying to explain black box models for high stakes decisions. Just full stop.
Which sounds counterintuitive. Right. Like, shouldn't we try to explain them?
Well, her argument was aimed at the popular tools of the time. Stuff like WIME by Ribeiro and colleagues or SHT by Lundberg and Lee.
Ah, right. The post hoc explanation tools.
Exactly. They generate an explanation after the AI has already made its decision.
I always think of those tools like an AI public relations department.
That is a perfect analogy.
Right. Because the AI does something weird and the PR department scrambles to look at the inputs and they issue a statement saying, well, the car probably break because of that pedestrian over there.
It sounds plausible. It tells a nice story.
But it doesn't guarantee that the pedestrian was the actual mathematical cause of the breaking. It was just a guess.
It is an educated guess about the AI's internal logic. Yeah. And that's exactly what Rudin was warning us against.
Because a PR spin is dangerous in a high-stakes scenario.
Right. For a movie recommendation, fine. But for robotic surgery or driving a car in Vegas, if the explanation isn't the literal load-bearing truth, you are being deceived.
She argued, we need inherently interpretable models from the ground up.
Exactly. But here's the crazy thing about the Nature paper we're looking at today. Kenny's team didn't build a new model from scratch.
No, they didn't. They took a massive opaque black box and they wrapped it.
Which sounds like they're just ignoring Rudin's warning. But they actually found this brilliant middle path.
Yeah, they built something called the Concept Wrapper Network, or CWNet.
Taking inspiration from a 2023 paper by Yuk Sekenal and others on post hoc concept bottleneck models.
So they took an existing black box and forced it to be inherently interpretable. Let's pop the hood on that original black box.
Yeah, let's talk about Drive RL.
Drive RL. It's an inverse reinforcement learning planner.
Right. And to break that down, standard reinforcement learning gives an AI a score to maximize. Like a video game.
You get points for not crashing.
Exactly. But inverse reinforcement learning works backward. They fed this AI roughly 80 hours of driving footage from human experts.
So it just watches humans drive.
Yeah. And its job is to figure out the hidden rules the human was trying to maximize.
Like inferring the unspoken rules of the road.
Exactly. Like, oh, the human always slows down when the lane gets narrow, so that must be a rule.
And it uses a really complex scene encoder to do this, right?
A hierarchical vector transformer. Instead of just looking at the road as flat pixels, it translates physical elements into math. Lane lines, crosswalks, moving cars.
So it's constantly calculating that, you know, car A is moving at a certain speed relative to pedestrian B.
Right. And based on that math, the trajectory generator proposes roughly 146 different candidate paths the car could take.
Every single step.
Every single step. Fraction as a second. In its original form, DriveIRL evaluates all those paths and a final, completely opaque reward layer.
It just picks the winner and we have no idea why.
None at all.
So how did Kenny's team fix that without throwing the whole model away? Because retraining it would cost a fortune.
It would take an eternity. So they did this fascinating architectural trick. They basically sliced off that final opaque reward layer.
Just chopped it right off.
Yep. And in its place, they inserted a concept classifier.
Okay, what does that do?
It acts as a filter. It looks at the scene and scores human-readable concepts. concrete things.
What kind of things?
Things like close, meaning the car is within three meters of another vehicle. Or ASV, which is approaching stopped vehicle.
Okay, so things a human driver actually thinks about.
Exactly. They also have bike, pedestrian, intersection, stop, slow, fast, and pickup zones, like Quito.
And they train this classifier on a ton of data, right? Like 500,000 scenarios just for eight concepts. Yeah,
up to 3 million scenarios for 10 concepts. But here is the critical part of CWNet.
Right, the new reward layer.
Yes. They add a brand new final reward layer on top. And this new layer is completely blind to all the complex vector math from before.
Wait, really? I can't see the original math.
Nope. The only thing it is allowed to look at are those human readable concept scores.
Wow. So that structural bottleneck is how they answer Cynthia Rudin.
Exactly. Because the final decision routes exclusively through these human concepts. The explanation is causally faithful by construction.
It reminds me of a corporate middle manager.
How so?
Well, imagine a manager who has to write down a checklist of concrete reasons before they approve a budget. They can't just say, my gut told
me to. They have to show their work.
They have to physically check the box that says approaching stopped vehicle. So if the car breaks, it is irrefutably because that box was checked.
It is the load-bearing truth. And here's the kicker. Yeah. Usually when you force an AI to be transparent, you pay a heavy tax on performance.
The model gets dumber.
Right. But on the massive new plan benchmark, wrapping this black box cost essentially zero performance.
Are you serious? Zero.
It performed within 1% of the original opaque model. The interpretability was basically free.
That's incredible. But I mean, the math working on a benchmark data set is one thing.
The real world is much messier.
Exactly. And that's the heart of this deep dive. They actually put human safety drivers in this car on a private track.
Yes, they did. And they documented three specific road stories that show how this alters a human's mental model in real time.
Let's talk about the first story, the pickup zone and the parked cars.
Yes. So the driver's on the track and the car keeps getting stuck near a pickup and drop off zone, a PUD.
And the human driver just assumes the zone itself is the problem, right? Like maybe the map data is confusing the car.
Perfectly logical assumption. If this were a black box, they'd just file a bug report saying it's broken at PUD zones.
But they had the CWNet explanations on the dashboard.
And the car wasn't confused by the pickup zone at all. The explanation showed the close concept was firing off the charts.
Because it was looking at parked cars nearby and panicking.
Exactly. It thought it was too close to them. So the driver physically takes the wheel, moves the car slightly away from the parked cars, and turns autonomous mode back on.
And it just starts moving perfectly.
Instantly. The close probability drops, and off it goes.
And the data backs this up. Across over 5,500 samples, the close concept correlated with speed at a Pearson R of about minus 0.56.
When close goes up, speed goes down.
So the explanation instantly corrected a faulty human assumption. They debugged the situation on the fly.
Right. But that was for real, physical cars. What happens when the sensors react to something that isn't there?
Ah, the second story. The traffic cone hallucination.
The car is driving along and inexplicably slams on the brakes next to a standard traffic cone.
And again, the driver blames the obvious thing. They assume the car doesn't know how to handle a cone.
The explanation shows the ASV concept approaching stopped vehicle is just spiking massively.
So it thinks the cone is a full-sized parked car?
It believes it's approaching a vehicle that does not exist.
And they proved it with a counterfactual test?
Yes. They removed the cone, drove the exact same road, and the car braked identically.
Wow. With the exact same ASV spike.
Exactly. The hallucination had absolutely nothing to do with the cone.
That is profound. AI hallucinations are so hard to pin down. If you were in a black box, you'd just be terrified.
But CWNet made the phantom visible. The driver could see the ghost the car was braking for.
That's wild. But the third story is the most honest one in the paper, I think.
The cyclist paradox.
Right. So the car approaches the cyclist, and thankfully, it successfully stops.
Which sounds like a win.
It does. But the engineers look at the dashboard, and the bike concept stayed under 1% the whole time.
CWNet completely failed to register the cyclist.
So why did it stop?
Well, they investigated. The car's raw perception system, the cameras and LIDARs, did see the bike.
Okay, so the eyes worked.
Yes. But the drive IRL planner, the brain, was never wired to consume those cyclist inputs.
It was essentially ignoring the cyclist.
Totally. It was on a trajectory to collide.
So what stopped it?
A completely separate, hard-coded emergency backup system kicked in at the last second and hit the brakes.
Oh, wow. So the explanation system showed a total failure of the planner.
And that is the paradox. A completely inaccurate explanation was the most valuable piece of information they got.
Because it exposed a massive blind spot. If they didn't have the dashboard, the driver would think... cool the ai handles cyclists perfectly
but because bikes stayed at zero they realized the core planner was dangerously blind
the authors actually argue that low accuracy concepts are off the valuable ones right
yeah because knowing when your ai is blind is just as important as knowing what it sees the safety drivers started approaching cyclists way more cautiously after that
it fundamentally shifted their mental model but you know those are just trap stories anecdotes
right does this actually scale Does it measurably improve situational awareness?
To answer that, they ran rigorous human studies, starting with some online replications.
Yeah, they tested nine emotional experts and 30 non-experts on Prolific.
And the results were pretty stark. Mental models improved for eight out of nine experts and 27 out of 30 non-experts.
And that improvement directly predicted how accurately people could guess the car's next move.
But the real test was the Las Vegas public roads study.
Oh, this was intense. A hundred participants out in the chaos of the Vegas Strip. And
they used SAGIT, right?
Yeah, the Situation Awareness Global Assessment Technique. It's usually used for fighter pilots.
To see if they're getting overwhelmed in the cockpit.
Exactly. They adapted it to see how well humans understand the dynamic driving environment, comparing CWNet against a control group that only saw speed and steering data.
And the results on surprising events were huge.
Massive effect sizes. For perception of the environment, Cohen's d was about 1.29. That's huge. For comprehension, 1.00. For projection, 0.61.
To put that in perspective for you listening, an effect size of 1.29 is the difference between panic and calm understanding.
It really is. But there was also a really counterintuitive finding.
Right. On ordinary, unsurprising driving, there was no significant difference whether they had the explanations or not.
Not at all.
Which, I mean, I have to push back on. If I buy an expensive, explainable car and it does nothing during my normal commute, I'd feel like it's broken.
You'd think so. But the authors frame this as the ultimate safety feature.
How so?
Well, think about cognitive clutter. If the dashboard is constantly screaming explanations at you when everything is fine, you get fatigued.
Ah, you just start tuning it out.
Exactly. It fades into the background normally and only commands attention when things get weird.
Which makes sense. And that concept classifier itself wasn't even perfect, right?
Deliberately imperfect. Its mean accuracy was only around 0.54. Wow,
so just over 50%.
It proves you don't need a mathematically flawless AI to vastly improve a human's mental model.
As long as it's causally faithful.
Exactly. Which
brings us to the broader implications, because this isn't just about cars.
No, the authors say this causal wrapper method can apply to autonomous drones, robotic surgeons, vision language action models.
Imagine a robotic surgeon making an unexpected cut. You want a causally faithful checklist showing exactly why it did that, not a post hoc PR guess.
And regulators are catching up. In the EU and U.S., explainability is being written into law.
So this won't just be a neat research trick. It might be a strict legal requirement to put a robot in public.
Very soon, yes.
But, you know, we have to leave you with the open question here. This was one system.
One company's planner.
Right. Tested by a small pool of experts using concepts a human had to hand label in advance, like bike or stop.
And the real world has an infinite, messy vocabulary.
Exactly. Does hand labeling concepts scale to the full chaos of the road? What if a mattress falls off a truck?
Or a flock of wild turkeys crosses the highway? Did anyone label a turkey concept?
Right. What happens when a self-driving car makes a fatal error based on a concept no human ever thought to label?
The dashboard would just be completely blank.
Because the AI is reacting to a ghost we never gave a name to, it is definitely something to chew on the next time you let a machine take the wheel.